Julia thank you have a number of young
people requiring hip operations due to
crash exercise fitness trends is rising
one clinic claims it seen a rise of 200
percent over the last two to three years
of patients in their mid-30s or younger
the South London talked to Henry Fredo
who had hip surgery earlier this year
and I think you've got 36 Henry what
happened to you yes at 36 years old now
I first found out about five years ago
that there was there was a small issue a
slight sort of physical deformity and
the head of the the ball of my hip where
it goes into the socket there was a
little spur and as I did exercise that
would and running or I play a lot of
squash when I when I would move the spur
would would would great inside the
socket loosening a bit of cartilage and
over time playing sport it just it just
got the pain got worse and worse and it
would be it would feel like that I had a
sort of stabbing pain inside my hip yeah
I mean there may be people watching you
think well a tiny little spur a little
tear of cartilage isn't going to do a
great deal but it can be extremely
painful can't it it can yes and it
actually wasn't when I was playing sport
that it was painful it was when I would
get up from the chair or pick my pick my
son up from his cot or something but
actually that's when it that's when I
noticed that the most or even sometimes
just walking so walk into work in the
morning not fully warmed up that that's
when I would feel it playing sport her
she wants the body was warm it was okay
but it was just day-to-day life and
actually that was quite that was quite
distracting for me what did your surgeon
say was he clear in saying that you know
that your physical activity the amount
of sport you were doing was contributing
to this I think it probably did
contribute I only found out I had
the issue as I said about five years ago
but it's been with me since I was born
so and I started playing squash when I
was about eight so 36 now whatever that
is my math isn't a good but but for a
long time just constantly rotating the
hip in the sport I play where you're
lunging up down left right it just
didn't do it any favors and so what is
happening now now that you've had the
surgery done I mean presumably your hip
is feeling a lot better but are you
having to cut back on the the type of
sport you're doing although the impact
of that sport well I had the operation
in January and I was told it would be
about six months till I could actually
play squash again four months till I
could start doing sort of gym gym work
so I'm in that process of rehab now I go
to the gym do stretching work on the on
the bike but I'm not doing any sport at
the moment which is a shame because I
love doing it but I'll be back yeah I'm
sure you will be about Henry good to
talk to you thank you very much indeed
no problem thank you